so sometimes going on a fast has the
potential to lower a thyroid hormone
called t3 and that's the active form of
the thyroid hormone t4 is the inactive
version so I'll explain why that is we
have the pituitary up here that
communicates of the thyroid through this
hormone called thyroid stimulating
hormone and one of the main ways that
hypothyroidism is diagnosed is by
looking at this hormone right here but
when you fast for the ketogenic diet and
do it healthily you're not going to see
a change in this hormone right here so
you are not going to have a true
hypothyroid condition or problem then
the thyroid releases t4 which is the
inactive form of the thyroid hormone to
become activated it has to work through
the liver into the kidney but it
converts from t4 to t3 and T is the
active form of the thyroid hormone but
there's something else over here called
reverse t3 and the difference between t3
and reverse t3 is that t3 is active in
Reverse t3 is an inactive version now
I'm not going to get into the technical
part of this but I just simply want to
tell you that what determines the rate
and ratio of this conversion to t3 or
reverse t3 is the metabolic need because
this has to do with preserving energy
when you do a fast you may see a slight
decrease in t3 and many times it'll
still be within the normal range but
you're going to see an increase in the
reverse t3 your body is simply becoming
more efficient with its fuel so the need
for the active thyroid hormone is going
to be a little bit less the body will
then put some of that hormone into a
little bit of a reserve until you need
it and it'll be released once you are
refeeding and you eat again there's
several situations where you'll see
higher amounts of reverse t3 when you're
doing fasting or when you're recovering
from a stroke or
injury or overtraining when you're
exercising or when you're recovering
from an illness or surgery or when you
just have lost a good amount of weight
reverse t3 will go up but one thing I
wanna show you is t4 usually represents
90% of all the thyroid hormones t3 will
represent about 9% of all the thyroid
hormones and reverse t3 usually
represents about 0.9% there is a very
small amount at four months it's like
point one that is designated for
something else because fasting slows the
conversion from t4 to t3 so it just
dumps out over here it's not a disease
State
you're still gonna feel fine you're
still gonna lose weight you're not gonna
have any of the symptoms but I think
it's important for you know what's
happening sometimes to certain people
when they do a fast as it relates to the
thyroid thanks for watching
hey back with another amazing recipe no
brains
no sugar totally Kido there's no
suffering PETA absolutely not Karen and
it's an immune system ilda absolutely
you have to check this out I think you
should hurry up watch the recipe and
make it yourself it's just so easy to be
keto but is it simple it's super simple
we hope you enjoy making it as much as
we are enjoying eating